des vêtements des accessoires ou encore
de la déco depuis le 1er décembre une
boutique éphémère de 180 m Carr a ouvert
ses portes dans les allées du centre
commercial Westfield parli 2 son nom
popéthique by toutes à l'école on y
trouve plein d'idées cadeaux pour les
fêtes dont l'intégralité des bénéfices
est reversée à l'association toutes à
l'école c'est tu G qui scolarise des
petites filles les plus défavorisées du
Cambodge ce sont des petites filles des
bidonville on les prend à la maternelle
et on les accompagne jusqu'à
l'université donc l'idée c'est de leur
transmettre une très très bonne
instruction et puis aussi de les aider
sur un plan médical d'aider les familles
c'est un très très gros campus voilà
donc c'est une aventure sur le long
terme une aventure dont la marine n'est
autre que la journaliste et
présentatrice du JT de 20h de TF1
annecler Coudret au sein de la boutique
les cadeaux proposés sont 100 % éthiques
ils ne font de mal ni à la planète ni
aux humains ni aux animaux une bonne
occasion de faire plaisir tout en
consommant autrement on se demande
toujours quoi choisir et il y a
tellement de choix de cadeau possible
que à un moment donné bah si on se dit
tiens ça a du sens c'est utile c'est
produit en France c'est éthique c'est
bon pour la planète bah ça peut nous
aider à faire notre choix et ça fait
plaisir aussi aux gens à qui on l'offre
et et donc je trouve que c'est c'est
c'est une très bonne idée et puis
c'était bien de s'inscrire aussi au
milieu d'un centre commercial parce
qu'il y a de la place pour tout le monde
desfites sous le signe de la solidarité
c'est ce que propose le centre
commercial Westfield parli 2 tout au
long du mois de décembre c'est étonnant
pour un centre commercial d'accueillir
ce team de boutique aujourd'hui on veut
réellement être des lieux de vie pour
nos visiteurs c'est ceux qu' le
recherchent et ce dont on a besoin vous
le voyez également avec la boutique
ressourcerie le petit bazar qu'on a
intégré pour la 3e édition cette année
et qui est situé à l'autre bout du
centre commercial et qui propose des
produits de second popétic by to à
l'école sera ouvert jusqu'à la fin du
mois de décembre la boutique se situe au
niveau zéro du centre commercial
installé au chîner au
cancours